Oh God oh my god Oh God
are my lips soft enough can you put on
too much chapstick probably
how does my breath smell should I brush
my teeth should i floss what was the
last time I went to the dentist what if
I'm not a good kisser what if she's not
a good kisser what if I bite her tongue
what if we both mean the same way and
hit noses what if I break her nose what
if I throw up in her mouth because I'm
so nervous
what if she throws up in my mouth whoa
what do I look like this close up oh I
should probably tweeze my eyebrows eyes
open eyes closed bedroom eyes oh god no
tongue tongue you got this go do it
why would you fly all the way from
America to England just to see me
because I have something to tell you
must be bloody important
why don't we stop there and let's take
it back - why would you fly all the way
back from America Bridget I want you to
sound a little bit more confused there
sure sure
alrighty great whenever you're ready why
would you fly it all the way from
America to England just to see me
because I have something to tell you
must be important
oh I'm sorry I messed up a line can we
take it back oh my god please yes go
ahead my little babies why would you fly
all the way from America to England just
to see me because I have something to
tell you Wow it must be very important
cuz I love it when you move - OH
right